we check in now with the great one I
call him the great one he's the host of
life liberty Levin weeknights uh weekend
Sunday at 9 00 p.m top show on the
network the great one Mark Levin Mark
I'll just hand it to you I know you got
a lot to say
president Trump was 76 years old
if the Department of Justice gets his
way he will die in federal prison
just by one of these counts conspiracy
to obstruct Justice which has a 20-year
maximum sentence
this is a disgusting
disgusting mark on American history for
the future to come
by these bandits in the White House by
the Democrat Party
that don't play fair anymore they don't
want to just win elections they want to
take control of this country they want
one party rule
and they have used the Department of
Justice and the FBI to get what they
want
Merrick Garland is a mob lawyer that's
what he is
Jack Reed is a rogue soviet-style
prosecutor
the presidential records Act is not a
criminal statute and it was never
intended to be the Espionage Act of 1917
was passed under Woodrow Wilson another
corrupt president
Woodrow Wilson used it to go after his
adversaries and they imprisoned two
thousand people
so I suppose over there at the
department of Injustice in this clown
prosecutor spent a lot of time at the
Hague they probably figured these laws
could be used to try and entrap Trump
all these obstruction issues that they
claim were the former Attorney General
Bill Barr comes up here and blow the
Yates about it and all the formers
coming on talking about obstruction they
have them on obstruction there'd be no
obstruction issue of any kind not even
in anybody's imagination had they not
criminalized this case
this is a document case
a document case where a president of the
United States were a former president
faces a hundred years in federal prison
is this some kind of a sick joke on the
American people Joe Biden says he never
told them what to do Joe Biden had to
sign off on that's becoming a national
archives case to have it go to the
Department of Justice who does he think
he's lying to the American people this
is a guy that's got documents from the
time he was in the U.S Senate for God's
sakes in his garage I don't want to hear
from the legal analysts the
technicalities about false statements
and obstruction this should never have
been a criminal case willful retention
of documents well what's the unwillful
retention of documents mean they're
throwing all these process crimes and
all these crimes that grow out of the
criminal investigation against Trump
what did he do with the documents did he
sell him to the Enemy No that's why we
we have an Espionage Act not the trick
of a president what did he do did he
burn them all no the government has all
the documents back so there is no
violation of the presidential records
act at this point but they throw the
book at him they go after his attorneys
they make them testify their attorneys
under the crime fraud exemption to
attorney-client privilege that means he
didn't have due process his own lawyers
were being subjected to interrogations
and they had hundreds of in a person
people testifying in front of grand
juries thousands of collections of
documents for what
For What and they indict him today they
indict them today in Miami all of a
sudden it's in Miami all of a sudden we
have a Florida grand jury because the
in Washington figured out that
there are venue issues that could lose
him his case this guy this prosecutor he
lost eight to zero in the U.S Supreme
Court when they overturned the
conviction of the former governor of
Virginia because this jerk took a
statute and expanded it a jury in North
Carolina wouldn't convict John Edwards
because this jerk took a campaign
statute and expanded it and he's taken
this case and he's undermining the
country and he's interfering with a
presidential election and let me be
clear as Jared said the Attorney General
of the United States made this final
decision this is not the independent
Council statute this is a special
counsel of appointed by the Attorney
General under a Department of Justice
regulation this attorney general who
pretends he's Helen Keller he made the
decision to indict the former president
and they made the decision to interfere
in this election you want to talk about
an Insurrection this is an Insurrection
and that's exactly what's going on here
let me go on Joe Biden is the crookedest
crook that's ever been in the Oval
Office everywhere we looked as a
predicate for a special counsel they
won't appoint a special counsel even
though it's compelled under the law in
which they appointed this special
counsel and you're not supposed to
appoint a special counsel against your
political opponent you're supposed to
appoint one in the case of Biden 20
shell corporations 10 million dollars
coming from the Communist Chinese
military spread out among the family no
businesses to support this endless
meetings endless meetings with with
bidens uh with Hunter Biden's business
partners Bob olinsky who ties Joe Biden
to the crimes Mr Big Mr 10 and what does
Biden say well then where's the money
he's asking us come and Catch Me If You
Can the idea that this man is isn't
under a criminal investigation and that
they criminalize the damn document case
to go after Donald Trump is sickening
and I would say this to our fellow
Americans don't be Bamboozled by these
cable channels and these fools who come
on and tell you well he's not above the
law are you kidding me Democrat attorney
general in New York Democrat prosecutor
in Manhattan Democrat prosecutor in
Atlanta Democrat attorney general in
Washington D.C what do you mean he's not
above the law there is no law what's
going on here is is a disgusting
disgrace it is war on trump it is war on
the Republican party and it is a war on
a republic the radical left is doing
what the radical left does while they
cover up for Biden the way they cover it
up for Hillary if Donald Trump is to be
charged like this Hillary Clinton should
have been charged with 10 000 counts of
obstruction because that's so many
emails she destroyed and five counts of
destroying cell phones because that's
how many cell phones they destroyed I'm
done and I'm sick of it
what you've said you know Mark many
years ago you said to me and you said in
one of your books we're in a
post-constitutional America and what
you're describing here when you said
they are the ones that are the uh that
are abusing the power that they've
criminalized uh political differences
that they weaponize the justice
department that's what you're saying
this they love the term Insurrection and
you're saying that's them they're not
abiding by the law they're not abiding
by the principle of equal justice or
equal application of of our laws am I
hearing you right
you're hearing me right and let me say
this
today what is today's date June 8th
June 8th is the day of insurrection not
January 6th a weaponized U.S attorney a
weaponized Attorney General of the
United States of unleashed the full
force of the United States government
against a former president the leading
Republican nominee to take on the
existing President we have never seen
anything like this in the United States
we saw it under Stalin we've seen it
another uh autocracies Marxist regime's
fascist regimes the third world but they
have taken the United States of America
and they have dragged us into a hellhole
this is embarrassing it's humiliating
and I'm going to tell you something
there are tens of millions of us you
have
cross the Rubicon twice which has never
been done and we will never forgive you
never ever and that's the bottom line
I'm done
Mark Levin thank you